5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about a viewer
email about a left turn signal that
might be on the fritz in the near
Southwest Valley
Tiffany writes a couple of weeks ago I
was trying to make a left turn onto
Hacienda from North on Rainbow wanted to
get over to Durango but I never got a
green light I watched the lights change
at least six times for all other traffic
I waited for traffic to clear ended up
making an illegal left turn because well
it was red nobody would let me in same
thing happened about a week later I
called the city of Las Vegas number they
said I needed to call Clark County but
didn't have a department name or number
it's scary and dangerous all right
Tiffany so as we watch the regional
transportation camera in that area it
did kind of look like uh it took a while
for a truck trying to make a similar
turn so I'm sending your concern over to
the folks on RTC so they can look into
it now Tiffany for you and actually
anybody else with a similar issue the
RTC encourages telephone tips like this
because sometimes that's the only way
they find out about a problem the phone
number
702-901-8400 we've got this in the
online version of this story when you
visit 8newsnow.com click on traffic then
drive many crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving crazy conversation
at traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com